and as the angle mentioned the green
monsters they really want to make
Private Car ownership a luxury
affordable only to the super wealthy
as for the rest of you if you need to
get somewhere you got to get creative
walk bicycle scooter Uber
I'd do that wherever you need to go if
you're heading into the city slip into a
bulletproof vest and take the bus to the
subway
Bloomberg is happily reporting that
soaring prices are making car ownership
a distant dream for middle class
Americans
and since EVS are more expensive they're
even more Out Of Reach now of course the
EU technocrats they love what's
Happening Here their Parliament just
passed a law to ban the sale of new gas
cars by 2035 mimicking California we
will move forward to green and
decarbonize our vehicle Fleet here in
the state of California as a consequence
substantially reducing greenhouse gas
emissions
Americans are being told that plug-ins
are going to help combat climate change
so do your part
one problem
that's another green lie a new report
from UC Davis found that ditching
gasoline-powered cars with electric
vehicles won't do much at all
certainly not if the goal is to be
carbon neutral eventually the only way
to get there would be to eliminate car
ownership for Millions upon millions of
Americans as Wall Street Journal is
noting progressives dirty little secret
is that everyone will have to make do
with much less fewer cars smaller houses
and yards and a significantly lower
standard of living
maybe Biden can turn that into a
campaign slogan
at least for once it'd be telling the
truth hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else